did you how did you know you were gonna
be one of the people who dissolve did I
well I didn't really didn't I mean it
was actually my my stunt man James young
that told me on set that day that you
know he was like all right mate well you
know we're gonna have this Matt and then
you're gonna fall and I was at work fall
where and and he was like you're just
here you're falling it cuz the thing but
that's the air and he never like
completed his sentences so it was always
like it's the thing from up there but
you know how's it going everybody right
now the hype for Avengers 4 is real
everybody's waiting for that trailer and
everybody's waiting to see what the
title is plus we have leaks and rumors
and cryptic photos from the Russo
brothers coming out every other day it
seems but none of this has actually been
officially confirmed by Marvel Studios
themselves so we really don't know much
about Avengers 4 yes there are a lot of
leaks and rumors that have a lot of
merit and backing behind them but
officially we don't really know anything
which is why everybody is so anxiously
awaiting the trailer but will the
trailer actually reveal what Avengers 4
is really about I'll break it down a
little bit in this video also I'm still
doing my giveaway giving away three
things a copy of Infinity Ward the art
of the movie art book a copy of infinity
war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray and some special edition
posters if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
yes the Avengers 4 trailer is going to
be amazing no matter what it is if
anything at all we get the official
title but well what we see in the
trailer be what we actually see in the
movie if you recall what the Russo
brothers did for the infinity war
trailers they put things in the trailers
that were not in the movie they also
altered scenes so that way we wouldn't
know what really happens in the movie so
people would dissect these trailers
myself included and try to speculate on
what happens in the movie based off the
trailer but sometimes what would end up
happening is that we dissect a fake
scene in what was really happening is
that the Russo brothers were being the
biggest trolls on the planet they didn't
know what was
I heard Benedict actually got a script
Benedict's got a script wasn't a real
scripture was a fake script you know I
don't know that anyone truly got the
real scripts as well and then you had
some of the actors going on TV shows and
radio shows doing interviews talking
about the movie but the problem with
that was they weren't really in the know
either we're very good at than saying
anything it takes a lot of energy to be
honest with you don't constantly be
filtering what you're so that's part of
the reason that you know we distributed
fake scripts to the cast is that it is
very hard to censor yourself and some
people are better at it than others so I
think that ultimately it was just best
for everyone involved so again we would
dissect what they were saying and try to
figure out some things about the movie
but in reality they didn't really know
the full true movie either but the truth
about all of this is that it's actually
all done for a really good purpose and
that is so we don't have any spoilers
trailers are supposed to get us hyped up
and excited to go see the movie the same
thing with interviews it's nice to hear
the actors talk about their favorite
parts and what they really enjoy about
the movie and give us a little bit of
info about it but not give the whole
thing away which is why the Russo
brothers and Marvel Studios went to such
a great extent to keep this movie as
secretive as possible and that includes
with the actors as well all of them got
fake scripts and some didn't even know
that they were going to die at the end
Anthony will know Anthony Russo one of
the one of the brothers of directors so
I went up to Anton I said Anthony what's
happening he goes talk to Joe so I went
up to Joe and I said hey Joe what's
going on he go did you talk to Anthony I
said yeah I know so what's and he was
like no oh you're just gonna you know
like am i dying you know but so it was
very cryptic but that's yeah so when it
comes to trailers and fake scripts we
can't really trust them 100% but it's
also we can enjoy the movie more and so
far the Russo brothers and Marvel are
being even more secretive with Avengers
for it than they were with Avengers
infinity war heck we don't even know the
name of the movie yet if you go to
Marvel calm and look up movies it just
says Avengers untitled so you know
they're going to even greater extent to
keep this movie on lockdown
but it's all because this is going to be
the biggest Marvel movie ever so far
probably one of the biggest movies in
general ever and they want us to enjoy
it and go into it knowing as little as
possible now having said that the
trailer that we do eventually get will
have a lot of what is actually going to
happen in the movie and there are
legitimate leaks that pop out so I'm
always going to dissect the trailers and
report on leaks because it's what I love
to do and I know you all love it as well
so be on the lookout for that first
Avengers 4 trailer that should be
dropping soon and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to Avengers
4 as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you